hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well there is a very interesting and
Illuminating discussion of idealism on
the part of Emanuel Kant in his proma to
any future metaphysics in part one where
he's discussing mathematics and he's
worked out the idea of a priori
intuitions and talked about mathematics
as working through space and time which
are indeed AR priori intuitions namely
the forms of our
sensibility and he's concerned with
whether he's going to be tarred as an
idealist which is kind of a dirty word
at the time and before we jump into
looking at that we should remark that I
think a lot of people if they have
gotten their ideas about Kant from
Reading secondary literature histories
of philosophy taking an inro to
philosophy class they know that Emanuel
Kant is you know one of The Originators
of what we call German idealism so
obviously he must be an idealist of some
sort right and yeah yes he is but he's
going to distinguish his conception of
idealism which he thinks is okay from
others which are clearly in his View
wrongheaded and he doesn't want to be
mixed up with those so he tells us in
remark
2 um that idealism consists in the
assertion that there are none but
thinking beings so I kind of and no
other and when we translate v as beings
okay that's not bad it could also be
Essences right beings makes more sense
here and you know typically when we
think about idealism as it gets
presented in a rather abstract manner
it's that well the entire world exists
for a thinker a perceiver however you
want to frame it and that you know the
things that we we see we sense they only
exist because we are sensing them and
perhaps there's a God who also senses
them you know alab Berle or perhaps they
have some sort of you know weird quirky
being of their own as with a card right
and so Kant says that um you know
whatever is given to us as object must
be given to us an intuition all our
intuition takes place by means of the
senses the understanding ints nothing
but only reflects and we've just shown
the senses never and in no manner enable
to know things in themselves but only
their appearances which are mere
representations of the sensibility so
isn't this manifest idealism we only
have uh appearances or Shin or um for
you know
representations and so you know this
could be idealistic and and Kant goes on
and he says on the contrary I say things
as objects of our senses existing
outside of ourselves are given there are
actual things out there however you
can't by means of the senses or is it's
going to turn out by the understanding
of Reason either these other faculties
we know nothing of what they may be in
themselves on zaps right knowing only
their appearances that is the
representations which they cause in Us
by affecting our senses and he says I
grant there's bodies outside of us we
just don't get to see what they are in
themselves we get to see them through
their appearances through their
representations that's as good as it's
going to get right that's what we
actually know and so he says listen I'm
not destroy destroying the existence the
existence here not dine but existence of
the thing that appears so you don't
really have to worry about that right
and he says is what I'm doing idealism
can it be termed idealism it is the very
contrary and then he says long before
locks time he's talking about you know
locks uh inquiries uh into how how our
understanding actually works and lo
placed a great emphasis on the
difference between primary and secondary
qualities lock also was very dubious
about her ever knowing the the very
substance of a thing either but long
before Lock's time it was granted and
assumed without detriment to the actual
existence of external things that many
of their predicates may be said to
belong not to the things themselves but
to their appearances so heat color and
tape
you know what we typically call
secondary qualities if I go further and
rank the uh as mere appearances the
other remaining qualities of bodies
which are called primary such as
extension place and in general space
with all that belongs to it like
immaterial materiality or
impenetrability shape nobody can aduce
the reason of its being inadmissible so
you know really K is carrying out a move
quite simp similar to what it is that
that Berkeley himself did and and Hume
did in their own work saying this
distinction between primary and
secondary qualities that we see people
like dick har and lock making it doesn't
really hold I mean it's all for the
they're all representations or
appearances for for us right so you know
should we call that
idealism Kant says not yet and he says
um
I should be glad to know what my
assertions must be in order to avoid all
idealism he's not going to actually
avoid all idealism he says I should say
the representation of space is not only
perfectly conformable to the relation
which our sensibility has to objects but
that it is completely like the object
and he says well that doesn't even make
any sense that's not a way to get out of
this and so in in remark three he goes
on and he says we can dismiss an
objection that by admitting the
ideality of space and time the whole
sensible world would be turned into mere
illusion shine in this case and that's
related to ainong appearance right so he
says um philosophical insight into the
nature of sensuous cognition was spoiled
by making sensibility merely a confused
mode of
representation what's this well you know
the the r nationalists you see this in
livets you see this in in deart right
also in in Spinosa to to some degree
right and he says um sensuous perception
represents things not at all as they are
but in the mode in which they affect our
senses right so we're always getting
just representations or appearances and
he makes a really important distinction
here appearance is given to sensibility
but sensibility doesn't actually engage
in the the judgment right and admitting
the ideality of space and time doesn't
mean the sensible World becomes mere
illusion it's the understanding that's
actually making judgments so we need to
look at the understanding and K is going
to go on and say listen I am saying that
space and time are forms of intuition
that we can't get away from we bring to
whatever is out there the things in
themselves but I also say we shouldn't
go beyond possible experience with these
Concepts from space and time and you
other people have been doing that how
have youve been doing that well he gives
you some examples if I Proclaim them
qualities inherent in things in
themselves I don't know the things in
themselves right so I can't say that
they are qualities in those things
or um you know uh other possibilities
would be saying
that um you know they could they could
be uh intu it in some other way some
grasp in some other uh mode well that's
not going to work either the only way
that's going to work according to khant
is what he is presenting in the critique
of pure reason and here in the prolom so
he doesn't want to go beyond possible
experience with these concepts of space
and time it doesn't mean the actual
experience any possibility
that we we could actually have and so
this is going to allow him to
distinguish different kinds of idealism
now he said that I want to avoid any
idealism altogether that's not going to
happen he is engaging in something that
he is perfectly willing to call a
certain type of idealism right and he
says that the critique of pure reason is
the proper antidote to the other types
of idealism and he says that this is the
only one that can actually prevent
falling into
Illusions so he says um I have given
myself my Doctrine the name of
transcendental idealism so do not
confound it with the empirical idealism
of
decart um or the mystical and Visionary
idealism of Berkeley our critique
contains the proper antidote as a matter
of fact you will find not talking
explicitly about those two thinkers as
well as many others in the critique and
so he says my idealism concerns not the
existence of
things because it never came into my
head to doubt that existence but it
concerns the sensuous representation of
things to which space and time
especially belong and he says I've shown
that space and time are neither things
but are mere modes of representation nor
are they determinations belonging to
things in themselves so this is an
advance according to to Kant past the
errors the erroneous types of idealism
espoused by great thinkers like Renee
deart and uh you know Bishop Barkley now
he's going to also call De cart's uh
empirical idealism dreaming idealism
there's a little dig at a cart earlier
on in this this uh part this discussion
of ideal ISM how can we actually tell
the difference between dreaming and
reality well it has to do with the
coherence of what it is that we're
experiencing the representations how
they're connected together I mean Dart
says something kind of similar but why
is is decart's idealism problematic here
dekart is really telling us we can
really only know uh in a certain way our
own thinking and the stuff that we're
getting from
outside um is merely probable we can't
be completely certain about it um
sensing is actually a mode of thinking
and it it only happens in a thinking
substance not in those external objects
Barkley is kind of going the other way
and saying you know all we really have
are these ideas about things we we can't
really know what we are we are spirits
uh God is also a spirit and Spirits by
their very nature are not ideas which we
can grasp in that way and Barkley will
go so far as to deny the existence of
what most people call matter so what is
deart doing um uh he he says that um we
we don't want to convert actual things
not appearances into mere
representations and then what is Barkley
doing changing mere representations into
things so we have dreaming idealism on
the one hand and then we have Visionary
idealism and he says both of which are
to be refuted by
my transcendental or better critical
idealism and why is it called critical
idealism because we are engaging in a
critique an examination of how things
work and the conditions for the
possibility for the knowledge that we
either have like mathematics or or could
have like a future metaphysics right so
Kant is in fact telling us yes this is a
kind of idealism it's not the kinds of
idealism that you are used to and that
you are rightly critical of and
rejecting what I'm doing is not saying
there is no external world it's just
saying the only way that we get to it is
through you know sensibility and then
the judgments that the understanding
forms about it and those are working on
representations foran or appearances or
shining and you know the conditions for
these for example uh you know space and
time as forms of sensible intuition but
also the basis of mathematics uh you
know understood in terms of arithmetic
and and geometry which we know actually
are
Sciences so K is showing us here what
kind of critical idealism he's espousing
and telling us to avoid
non-critical
idealism